today I'm going to share some things
with you that I have never shared before
and never would I have imagined that the
way I'd be sharing them for the first
time would be public for Millions to see
but when God writes Your Love Story
healing can be found in the most
unexpected of ways my friend I am a True
Believer in Happily Ever Afters I
believe that you are created by a loving
God to love and to be loved and I
believe that you are worthy of Love
today I'm going to share my love story
but I've got to warn you it's going to
get deep we might want some tissues for
this one hey there I'm Jessie I've been
happily married to my best friend for
over 7 years now between dating and
marriage we've shared nine of the best
years of my life together and have
welcomed two kids into our family almost
a decade later I am still in love I
still get excited when he gets home from
work and he's still my lover that I'm so
thankful to have met but let's just say
that our first impression started off on
the wrong foot in a previous video 10
odd things I quit since adopting
minimalism I briefly described my first
encounter with my husband and how it was
not a good first impression at all I'll
leave the video down below so you can
check that out after this but to
summarize I thought that he was an
unsympathetic jerk and he thought that I
was a lazy selfish brat and today I want
to share the full story it's a story of
how two Polar Opposites though very much
broken in their own ways found healing
in the most unexpected way first big
thanks to Sharice for requesting this
video because I wouldn't have thought to
make it if you hadn't asked but I'm
really glad that you did because I love
love stories I am that crier at weddings
between people I don't even know because
I believe in Happily Ever Afters and I
believe that you are worthy of love in
sharing my love story I am in no way
saying that we have the perfect marriage
nobody does we are both very much a work
in progress but I hope that the story is
encouraging to you because it's not all
ponies and sunshine with my husband's
permission I will be sharing bits of his
life as well as my own trials and it's
important context because it will show
how these two very broken people though
very much imperfect were perfect for one
another and that the hardships that we
faced were in a way necessary for us to
be led together and find Healing
together but before I begin I do need to
mention that I will talk about sexual
abuse in this video no details will be
shared but I do want to be fully
transparent I am not one that likes to
filter comments but because of the
nature of what we're going to be talking
about any negative or judgmental
comments in this regard will be deleted
comments like it's your fault or how
could you let that happen are not only
not helpful but they can be hurtful and
you just never know what somebody else
watching this video might have gone
through or might be going through right
now and I do not want any man or woman
who's experience such traumas to feel
ashamed or to feel alone unfortunately
the statistics show that it's much more
common than we might think so please
please please please be kind and
encouraging in the comments not for me
but for everybody else El that's going
to be watching this video after you I
also need to be clear that I'm not a
counselor and I'm not a mental health
professional I'm not giving any advice
I'm only sharing how with my willingness
God completely transformed my life and
led me to the perfect man for me okay so
before I share my story let me first
share a glimpse into my husband's youth
he also grew up in Mexico but he was on
a whole another level of poverty for me
his family did not have electricity or
running water and his father was a truck
driver who was often gone for weeks to
months at a time though at one point my
mom my brothers and I shared one plate
of food between all of us I thank God we
at least had food on many occasions my
husband's mom would have absolutely
nothing to feed her five children and
when my husband or his sisters would ask
for food she would tell them to take a
nap while she prepared food promising
that once they woke up she would have
food prepared there was no food
distracting them was all that she could
do because of malnourishment Rudy was a
a sickly kid often struggling with nose
beds diarrhea and other ailments and
unfortunately this alone made him the
perfect Target for bullying before he
was even a teenager he faced hunger he
faced bullying and even witnessed a man
be murdered before his eyes but despite
that traumatic event at a young age what
actually changed his world forever was
when he came to know the reason why he
and his sisters often went hungry his
dad had a mistress with three other
children with whom he spent most of his
off days with and as well as his money
my father-in-law was not at all ashamed
when his 10-year-old son found out and
instead told him that this made him a
man and that it was time for him to be
one as well and he took my husband to a
place where no child no child should
ever be taken and his hero fell crumbled
before his eyes and after this uh he
developed deep anger for his father
to the degree that he had to move with
his
grandparents because when his dad beat
him he now fought back and it wasn't
safe for him anymore when he learned
that his father had been happily
indulging in his own Pleasures while he
and his sisters went hungry and sick he
vowed that he would do everything in his
power to be the opposite of what his
father was and that if he ever became a
father he would be faithful he would be
devoted and protect his family at all
costs he saw how his father hurt his
mother a woman who once had Joy and a
sparkle in her eye and he never wanted
to hurt a woman in this way so this is
just a tiny Peak into a lot of other
heartbreak but now let's rewind a bit to
my childhood and take a look at
12-year-old Jessie I've shared that my
childhood was not the happiest I lived
in poverty in Mexico until I was almost
seven with my mom and my two brothers
and then eventually when my dad saved
enough money we all moved here with him
in the US and it was miserable I was
bullied at school my parents had a
broken marriage so there was often
cursing and yelling and slamming of
tables crying to sum it up I was the
lonely child who hungered for love and I
often cried myself to sleep at night
wishing that my life would just end I
think that I blocked out a lot of my
childhood because there are a lot of
things that I just don't remember but
when I was around 12 years old I had a
profound experience that I will never
forget I was in the living room watching
some movie on TV where a couple was in
love and the young man opened up to the
girl that he loved he told her that he
wanted to marry her and spend his life
with her but that he couldn't have sex
with her because he had been sexually
abused this is already making me tear up
I was just a kid I had never been
through such a thing so I didn't know
what that felt like and I couldn't
relate to his pain at all I was really
pretty naive to what it all even meant
but I remember watching his pain as the
young woman rejected him and cut off the
relationship I don't remember the rest
of the movie because I was in tears at
that moment I was completely oblivious
to whatever else was going on around me
and even though I was just a child I
turned my heart towards God and I said a
prayer that I meant from the bottom of
my soul and I said these words almost
for btim I said God if there is a man
out there that this has happened
to and he's going to be
rejected give him to me I will love him
I will be patient with him and I will
never reject him
and I cry not because I
hurt but because in retrospect it all
makes sense
now God would eventually answer my
prayer but little did I know that in
order to understand this man and for him
also to be a strength for me I would
have to face my own
beasts so fast forward a few years when
I was a teenager and I had my first love
love I was Flying high in the clouds and
it was the first time in my life that I
had ever felt seen and longed for loved
and it was an intoxicating feeling that
quickly became toxic I've also shared
that I was a Shopaholic that had a huge
assortment of makeup and accessories and
I can now see that it was all
intertwined it was all a mask and it
stemmed from my lack of self-worth I
kept trying to obtain love and
validation from the people in my life
and I couldn't see my own intrinsic
value I was a straight day student and I
tried to be a good kid but no matter
what I did I always still just felt
invisible and even though sometimes I
would pray I really didn't have a
relationship with God at that time and I
didn't have other relatives or positive
friendships that I could turn to and in
this sad relationship I was eventually
forced to do something that I did not
want to
do that
day I was
confused I knew it felt wrong
I knew that my no was not
respected but I didn't think of it as
abuse because I was in a
relationship it took me some time to
actually really figure out what had
happened and and come to terms with that
but after that every time I saw even
minimal intimacy scenes and movies I was
disgusted to the point that I would
become physically
nauseous I couldn't stand and seeing
people kissing or hugging in public I
hate to admit that I was in this
relationship for some time after that
and eventually we weren't dating anymore
but we were still talking as friends
which was just as toxic and probably
even more emotionally draining but in
the meantime I was becoming more and
more broken inside and so I turned to
God I began assisting church I attended
an amazing Retreat that really gave me
hope and I started attending a small
group and eventually I was given the
answer that I was looking for
one day I prayed to God for a clear sign
that would show me which direction to
take I know the signs had been shown but
listen I was honest with God and I told
him that I needed it to be so obvious
that it would slap me in the face and
that sign came the very next day through
my now husband who at that time was only
an acquaintance at that point in his
life he was very very involved in the
church and because I had become more and
more involved I we knew of who we were
but we weren't friends yet around that
time I had lost a lot of weight over 20
lbs to be exact and people would often
comment asking if I was sick and if I
was okay I remember one specific person
well-intentioned
individual commenting saying that I
looked decrepit and I remember thinking
to myself well thanks like that helps me
feel any better at that time Rudy had no
romantic intentions with me but he says
that he would feel sad to see a healthy
looking girl suddenly turn to bones and
just always look sad Rudy is definitely
a giver and he's always willing to give
to people who are in need and he tells
me that he would often give gifts to
people that would remind them of God's
love and that he had made a drawing of
Jesus and made a rosary that he intended
to give to somebody else but one day
while he was working on something else
out of nowhere he just suddenly felt
that God told him to give those things
to me he's honest and he said that he
really didn't want to do that because we
weren't even really friends and he felt
that it might be awkward but he did as
God led him to do so that day he decides
to give me this drawing of Jesus and a
beautiful handmade Rosary he had wrapped
it in a small envelope and told me to
open it when I was alone confused
because I barely knew him I took the
envelope and I said Thank you and later
that afternoon as I drove home I just on
this particular day I really didn't want
to walk in the door of my home and
pretend to be happy for my family not
today for some reason I just felt a
sudden urge to pull over and funny
enough the next turn where I could park
was a big empty parking lot of a church
that had a big red sign on it
saying stop suffering I had completely
forgotten about the envelope so as I sat
there staring at that sign I felt a tug
that I needed to open it the moment that
I opened my
gifts that was my slap in the face
moment
that was the sign that I had prayed for
for context I didn't really pray the
rosary but the guy that I was chaining
myself to was a Jehovah's Witness and to
be clear I'm not at all attacking
Jehovah's Witnesses but he had never
given me a wrapped gift because they
don't celebrate Christmas or birthdays
and much less would he have ever been
able to bring me to Jesus which is what
my heart really longed for tears rolled
down my face like a river that day
because I knew that this man I had to
cut all ties and never look back it was
clear to me now that I needed a man that
could lead me to Jesus not a guy who
didn't know what it meant to protect a
woman and I listened to God this time
some call it the gut feeling like when
my husband randomly felt that he had to
give that gift to me even though he
didn't really know me some call these
things
coincidence I call it God I was willing
to let go and leave my desire to be
loved by another and this was what
amazingly freed myself to love myself
and once I could love myself again I
could then love another but what's funny
in all of this is that I was still so
oblivious to what God was saying that I
never really connected the dots between
what the sign that I had prayed for and
that the Gift Giver was part of that
sign I never even considered it but it
actually needed to happen this way so
that I could first love myself and what
ended up happening is that because I had
felt so broken I submerged myself even
more in service and just focusing on
filling my cup and I know that it was
divine hands working on this because for
some reason we just always seem to end
up working together on organizing one
thing or another so the beauty of how
this relationship bloomed is that we
first became friends before anything
else he wasn't looking for Love at the
time that he had met me he had tried and
tried to find love and faced a period of
years where he felt frustrated with God
because he felt like he was getting old
and his time was running out and by the
time that we met he was so filled by God
that he didn't really worry about that
anymore anymore and honestly the idea of
me liking him never even crossed his
mind or mine to be honest because he was
over 10 years older than me his English
was not perfect and he was going bald
truthfully the idea of me dating
somebody older never even crossed my
mind and I find it funny that I had been
asked out by guys that were like seven
or 8 years older than me and I had been
creeped out but when I was with him I
felt peace I felt calm I felt safe the
more that we spent time together the
closer that we became first we were just
brother and sister in faith but
eventually he became my best friend and
having come to first know his heart is
what then allowed me to see him as the
man that I wanted to spend my life with
I get sad when people first focus on the
attractiveness of their partner and then
they worry about all the details later
the reason that I could fall in love
with my husband was precisely because he
didn't pursue me for my exterior I don't
care how beautiful or hot you are your
body will age and wither away I dig a
few guys after that but I couldn't see
them as men I wanted a man that would
protect and value his woman and that
knew what he wanted but in order for me
to have that I first had some growing up
to do so that I could be clear on what
it is that I wanted and for him to be
that man that knew what it is that he
wanted he had to go through the trials
that he went through our marriage hasn't
been without disagreements but we have
never yelled or cursed at each other and
the word divorce is just strict strictly
forbidden in our marriage there's also a
lot of things that we do that I think
some people would probably think that
we're a bit extreme on for example
neither of us have social media
platforms like Facebook or Instagram or
those sorts of things and for the most
part we don't really have friends of the
opposite sex and if we do they're
generally more of acquaintances and we
only hang out when we are all together
but we value our relationship so much
that if we have to be like a rabbit
animal when you take its food away
that's just the way it's going to be
there's definitely a lot of other things
that I've noticed that we do differently
that has helped us to have a very happy
marriage that may not be perfect but
it's two people that are still in love I
mean after a few years usually people
say oh that exciting feeling of waiting
for your lover to come home is it it
Withers away for me that has never
happened my husband was just recently in
Mexico and he came home early cuz he's
like I miss you like and I'm I was glad
because I miss him too I mean we are two
people that are still genuinely in love
and that's I
think the things that we do have
definitely helped in to maintain that
feeling of being in love and not just
two people that love each other and take
care of each other I want to preserve
the in love state but I think that
that's a whole another separate video
that I could talk about if that's
something that you're interested in then
just let me know down in the comments
and if not then just say no thanks but
moving back to our story the first
couple of years in our marriage we were
very patient with each other and
encouraged each other in relationship to
the traumas that we had faced I lived
out my 12-year-old yes's promise to God
and he lived out his PR promise to
devote himself fully to his family and
his children he promised this to me when
we were dating and he has kept this
promise to this day that he has never
forced me to do anything that I don't
want to do and I know that he means it
when he says that he would lay down his
life for me and our
children and boy did God bless me with a
man that treats me like a princess who
wakes up at 4:30 a.m. and makes me
breakfast every day that I live with
this incredible man I am living living
my happily ever after but I know that
it's because we heard God's voice and we
said yes you might think that we're
crazy lunatics but our first date was
sitting on a rock at the park reading
the Bible and watching the sunset as I
sat beside him on that rock on our first
date I knew that he was the one this oil
painting that R made shows the sunset on
our first date on the way to the sofa
looking Rock which has since been
covered up by water there was a
misshapen heart that had rocks that said
I love you in the center but many of the
stones were out of place so we stumbled
past it as we walked and then proceeded
to fix it together we spelled out I love
you with those rocks with this broken
heart that was misshapen we formed one
whole heart that was no longer
broken I wish I had taken a photo of
that heart
because I now know that it was the
symbol of what God wanted for us and
what what he would do for us together it
took one date and we knew that this is
where we needed to be we had found our
home if you've made it this far in this
video thank you it really means a lot to
me this video is very special to me and
I cry not because of pain but out of
pure awe of how the things that I once
thought I could never overcome were
precisely the things that I needed to
lead me to the incredible love that I
get to have today and I'm so thankful I
am thankful for the trials and I know
that my husband says he would live all
that he lived through all over again if
it meant that we could be together again
I know that you also have an incredible
story because you are valuable you are
worthy and you are loved I genuinely
hope that this video has been an
encouragement to you and helps you in
some way and for those of you who are
new this channel focuses on minimalism
and living a fulfilling life with less
but as you can tell we don't just
scratch the surface here I'm not just
going to sit here and talk about
decluttering and making your home pretty
even though I do that too I want to be
that friend that's there with you as you
declare what's in here too so if you
want to not only simplify your home and
your life or your schedule but you want
to live an abundant fulfilling life with
less let's learn together and hit that
subscribe button so you won't miss when
I post a new video also be sure to give
it a thumbs up so more people can hear
this message or share with a friend to
my subscribers I recently had my
computer break and I lost a few videos
and scripts as well as a project that I
was working on for this channel that was
really special to me but I'm totally
okay if I did it once I can do it again
and hopefully better this time but that
being said it might take me some time to
get back into the groove but if there's
any specific videos that you'd like to
see from me be sure to let me know down
in the comments below or shoot me an
email thank you so much for watching
until next time bye for now